we are indeed with a local superstar ray
robson after an incredible victory ray
first of all congratulations welcome to
the studio how does it feel to be back
here in saint louis playing over the
board chas
uh yeah thanks it feels good to be
playing again also of course good to get
a win i mean alex is
probably my hardest ever opponent
considering raiding i think i'm usually
slightly higher rated but
i mean he's beaten me several times and
i think i maybe beat him once in our
recent games when we had like many draws
which was
a good accomplishment for me because
before that i was losing a lot of games
and yesterday also was a razor sharp
battle against hans nemos tell us a
little bit about that as well yeah that
was a very interesting game i mean hans
well we played a very theoretical line
which i guess was expected because hans
seems to be very well prepared and in
general
so we played a line where we were
actually following a game between uh
abdusthatsurov the world rapid champion
and anishikiri
and i think i deviated from that game
with the move g5 uh we both knew about
this game i just couldn't remember
during the game whether anish played
knight d7 first or whether g5 was played
first
so i just kind of thought on my own and
i thought g5 might not be what he played
but it should be
should be a reasonable move anyway and i
think how do you feel about the tactical
battle that ensued towards the time
control yeah i mean
i missed one move of his queen a2 which
um
even though objectively i should still
be okay after that uh it kind of changed
the balance of the game and then after
that i was struggling because i was low
on the clock and there was a lot of
pressure in my position and i played the
move c5 which
um weakened d6 which was a big mistake
and after that yeah he i felt like he
should be winning there um
but he missed his chances he should have
been a little bit more decisive there
and yeah after the time control actually
i was the one who had chances and
actually had a few
wins they weren't super obvious but
um in general it was very unpleasant to
play his position so
yeah it was a little bit disappointing
that i couldn't win from that point but
on the other hand
um it was good that i didn't lose the
game so i guess the draw was kind of a
fair result well yesterday his history
today was a much smoother game take us
through that
yes so
we got an um
a little bit of an unusual line i mean
he played one of the main lines with g6
and
d5 and the line i played against it with
h3 c5 is
is known but
normally white just captures on d5
immediately but this is an interesting
way to play because you stop bishop g4
and the idea is you want to put the
bishop on b5 and you always have the
idea to take the knight off on c6 and
you control
e5 very well and
yeah it seemed like alex didn't really
know this line too well although the way
he reacted was logical so castles
we should be 594 castles and i think
this is
still the main line and i believe queen
a5 is supposed to be the best move here
most likely
but he took and he played queen c7 so i
wasn't really
super familiar with these positions
um i just assume white should be
somewhat better but i wasn't sure how
because
black
is obviously aiming to play b6 and break
up my pawn on c5 and after that
structurally it feels like black's
completely fine at least that's how it
felt to me so
i figured i should try to at least
develop a temple so rookie one bishop g5
made sense
queen d2
b6 all very logical yeah now bishop h6
was interesting basically i was trying
to scare him
uh make him afraid that i'm exchanging
darks for bishops is bad for him and try
to make him play bishop f6 or bishop h8
and i thought
in either square it's like a slight
improvement for me compared to having
his bishop on g7 which is um kind of
funny so he went bishop h8
and then
yeah the whole time i've been planning
to play bishop f4 at some point but here
i realized maybe it makes sense to just
give up on the idea of maintaining that
sort of pressure and switch to the king
side so i took
and played h4 and suddenly h5 is coming
um
it's nice that i have this bishop on h6
versus the bishop on h8 suddenly his
king feels a little bit shaky and i
think here is where he probably started
to feel
some pressure and
yeah for the rest of the game i felt
like i was definitely the one putting
pressure on him i wasn't sure
about the objective evaluation i thought
i had some advantage but um i think his
decisive mistake was definitely queen a8
we were shocked about that movie yeah i
i also
like i saw him he had a few minutes
before he had kind of reached for the
queen so i thought okay maybe he wants
to play queen a7
but i thought that was also a bad move
because queen a7 maybe just queen e2
and if rook takes a2 i have rook takes
e7 is very nice mate if he takes e2
i take on e8
rook takes e8 rook takes ca king g7 and
i have h6 king f6 and
mate with the bishop somewhere
so
yeah and in general if he's losing e7 i
thought my position is probably close to
decisive so i i didn't understand i
assumed he realized that and then he was
going to make a different move but then
he played queen a8 which was like even
more surprising
um yeah did you talk to him after the
game did he say what he yeah i just it
seemed like i don't know to me i
evaluated that he just can't give up e7
um he did obviously miscalculate
something so after rookie 7 rookie 7
bishop f6 i was pretty sure the only
reason he could have gone for this is
because he thought after let's say
rookie one
that he could at least take back on a2
which you actually can't because i can
do the same trick with queen a2 rookie a
and h6 mate
um
so
he definitely he did blunder this he
told me after the game so i could have
just gone rookie one and my position
should be close to winning um but then i
thought queen e3
might be objectively like much stronger
so i thought about it for a good while
and then
i went for i mean just in general
principles like the dark square
weaknesses in black's position me having
this bishop and my king is super safe
like it has to be winning but of course
i i try to calculate some lines
so he played f6 which actually didn't
see at all probably the best practical
defense
i think what i did looked very logical i
stopped him from going to f8 with his
queen so he's really tied down
b5 i believe he played
knight e5 queen e8
yeah and here i spend a lot of time
because i completely hallucinated
something i thought he actually can't
move
like either his rook or his queen really
anywhere so i can kind of just do
whatever i want i can play d5 d6 d7
um and suddenly i realize if d5 he
actually has one move which is queen e7
so i couldn't find the force wind there
and i got pretty low on time
but it felt like i was still probably in
control um
with what i did but i wasn't completely
sure
it seemed clean enough to us at least uh
from the commentator's booth uh that it
was just fully controlled uh from start
to finish
after d6 is just e6 was a
yeah after d6 it was definitely over he
can't take his queen b7 and
otherwise the knight comes to e7 he's
just getting mated so after this it was
over just came down to the simple
principle of king safety and definitely
your king was much safer than his
ray congratulations a very good start
for you and uh good luck in the rest of
your games thanks and i started there
with one and a half